تاريخيه واستراتيجيه هكذا وصفت اوكرانيا
زياره الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
زياره موسقت مسبقا مع موسكو وجرت بعد رحله
استغرقت 10 ساعات على متن قطار قادم من
بولندا وهي تاتي عشيه دخول الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا عامها الثاني وبعد المباحثات
جرى اعلان دعم امريكي اضافي لاوكرانيا
مقابل عقوبات اضافيه على روسيا لذلك
بنينا تحالفا من شمال الاطلسي الى المحيط
الهادئ يضم النيتو اليابان وعبر العالم
اكثر من 50 دوله ساعدت اوكرانيا وامنت لها
دعما اقتصاديا وعسكريا وانسانيا غير مسبوق
في وقت لاحقين من هذا الاسبوع سنعلن عن
عقوبات اضافيه ضد النخب والشركات التي
تحاول التهرب من العقوبات ودعم اله الحرب
الروسيه
الرئيس الاوكراني
الذي وصف محادثاته مع بايدن بالمثمره اكد
ان نتائج هذه الزياره ستكون ملموسه في
تعزيز القدرات الدفاعيه لبلاده معجم
يمكننا ويجب علينا ان نجعل هذا العام عام
النصر هذه الحرب الاجراميه غير المبررته
روسيا ضد اوكرانيا وكل اوروبا والعالم
الديمقراطي يجب ان تنتهي بتطهير الاراضي
الاوكرانيه من الاحتلال الروسي جنبا الى
جنب مع السيد الرئيس بايدن ومع حلفائنا
وشركائنا يجب ان نواصل بدل كل ما في وسعنا
حتى يفوز العالم الديمقراطي في هذه
المعركه التاريخيه
ويترقب الاوكرانيون طبيعه الدعم الامريكي
الجديد وتداعياته على المعارك المحتدمه
على اكثر من محور وجبهه لاسيما مع توقع
اوكرانيا معارك اضافيه في المرحله المقبله
جدا وخصوصا ان اوكرانيا تستعد لهجوم
المضاد لاستعاده المزيد من الاراضي وتبعث
هذه الزياره رساله هامه وقويه لروسيا او
للشركاء ايضا بان دعم الولايات المتحده
لاوكرانيا في اعلى مستوياته
وبينما كان بايدا يزور قلب العاصمه ويضع
اكليلا من الزهر امام الجدار التذكاري
لقتل الحرب كانت صفارات الانذار تداوي في
ارجائها
فكياف ما زالت في عين العاصفه بعد مرور
عام على وصول القوات الروسيه الى ابوابها
قبل الانسحاب لاحقا سيناريو تتاهب
اوكرانيا لمواجهه احتمال تكراره
زياره مفاجاه للرئيس الامريكي الى
اوكرانيا حملت الكثير من الدلالات
والرمزيه والاهم انها حملت دعما سياسيا
وعسكريا ومعنويا اضافيا تتطلع اليه كياف
عشيه دخول الحرب الروسيه عليها عامها
الثاني كاترين حنا الجزيره كياف